I had a wild holiday man had some
pheasant or something if you read that
no I don't need a lot of gamy food
yeah Rogan Bryan talks all day about
pheasant would you go back home you know
went back to Louisiana and it was you
know I've never been anything up in the
dark arts like a PDF file or anything
like that and I don't believe in that
kind of [ __ ] if anybody's out there
doing that shut it down but I don't do
PDF files oh yeah
party with children yes and but I'll say
this do when you have them if you're
eating pheasant dude there's a party
when you crack it into this little thing
you're like this is this simile God
wanted frogs have you ever had have
you've had him come on guy I'm surprised
to know no doubt dude can eat sushi from
7-eleven baby bird yeah man it's
something it just was killed early it
seems like you know we're talking about
that
that's veal too right yeah it feels the
same thing that just doesn't seem right
to me yeah yeah they don't let's don't
let it move and then let's [ __ ] eat
it got it well and you're eating the
hips and butt of it really yeah it's so
[ __ ] okay that man is the regular beef
not good enough for a men it's just too
much when you cuz this little thing you
have to like move its legs
it's soni and the legs like cut want to
fall off in your hand throwing it up and
catch it kind of savages made pheasants
people call this hippie yeah we have
people in Mississippi man they'll eat
anything out there dude they'll [ __ ]
need anything I had a friend of Mines
aunt died out there a turtleneck she got
at war tight total night for like nine
days in a row and it cut off her [ __ ]
windpipe and killed her it's like this
is the tightest turtleneck of all time
wasn't that tight but she wasn't that
strong and she was getting older over
like over time and she didn't change
your shirt so a lot of that's on her you
know yeah who's the blame here you know
I'm saying well they tried to sue the
company
was that who made that [ __ ] bum
equipment with that nag boy that's a
fragile instrument you know did Stussy
make your [ __ ] turn I don't like to
come back though they're back they're
back as killers dude
yeah the silent killer is no longer
emphysema son it's that [ __ ]
turtleneck dude you were for eight days
and then it shut er down boy
ah do me it was just her time to go you
know if a turtleneck get you out of
there that's right go time yeah then God
wants you you know this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]